okay let's start hello my name is Vlad
Akana
and when I was nine years old I had this
crazy dream of writing my own computer
games and so I've learnt the cold as you
might imagine since then I didn't write
any games whatsoever but somehow for the
last eighteen years I ended up playing
the game of battling the complexities of
enterprise after Cronus serves the chief
architect for a company called internals
and the peculiar thing about inter
novels is that we've been using domain
driven design since the first day our
company was founded and I'm here today
to share with you our DVD journey I
divided this presentation into two parts
in the first one I'll walk you through
the various systems from our domain and
how we've implemented them now of course
I won't be able to cover everything
we've done so therefore I will
concentrate on five button context that
demonstrate the different approaches to
DDD that we've tried and the results
that we've achieved in the second part I
will use those five stories to share
some practical advice on the my driven
design domain modeling security when
sourcing micro services all based on our
experience at internals so without
further ado about seven years ago I've
got a phone call from a friend he said
that he was starting a new company the
business was not going to be simple but
if I'd join him technically I could do
whatever I wanted and since back then I
had a pretty boring job I have agreed
just like that let me show you what I've
got myself into
so you're producing a product or service
in turnovers allows you to outsource all
your marketing related chores well come
up with the best marketing strategy for
a product our copywriters and graphic
designers will produce tons of creative
materials such as banners and landing
pages that will be used to
you run campaigns to promote your
product all the leads generated by these
campaigns are going to be handled by our
own sales agents who will make the calls
and solar products and most importantly
this whole process provides many
opportunities for optimization and
that's exactly what our analysis
department is doing they are going to
analyze all this data to make sure that
our clients are getting the biggest bang
for their buck bid by pinpointing the
most successful campaigns most effective
creatives or by making sure that the
agents are working on the most promising
needs that's the system that I signed up
to build and since we were a self-funded
company we had to get rolling as fast as
possible
therefore we started by implementing the
first third of our value chain we had to
provide a system for media buyers to
manage contracts with various publishers
a catalog for our designers to manage
their creatives and of course a campaign
management solution to run advertising
campaigns which meant not only a
management system but an advertisement
advertisement hosting and serving
solution as well
now I don't know about you but back then
these business domains sounded terribly
complex to me fortunately not long
before we started working had read the
book with its title promising to help to
help to tackle such complexities and of
course I'm talking about Eric Evans
seminal book domain driven design
deadline complex stay in the heart of
software who read this book and who read
this book beyond the first chapter
three hands okay to be honest it's not
an easy book to read and luckily for me
like most of you I felt that I've got a
really strong grasp of domain-driven
design just by reading the first four
chapters guess how the system was
initially designed its architectural
style could be summarized as aggregates
everywhere creative agency advertiser
publisher for plasma campaign each and
every noun in the requirements was
proclaimed as an aggregate and of course
all those so-called aggregates resided
in a huge loan bounded context exactly
the same monolith that everyone warns
you about nowadays and of course those
were now aggregates they didn't provide
any transactional boundaries and they
had very little behavior in them just a
typical anemic domain model that only
describes the data structures all the
behavior on the other hand was here in
this enormous service layer now let's be
honest this design is no work of art
there was like by the book example of
how you not do the main driven design
right however things looked quite
different from the business standpoint
from the business point of view this
project was considered a huge success
because despite this imperfect
architecture and despite our very unique
approach to QA we
we delivered working software in a very
aggressive time to market how did we do
it and the answer is ubiquitous language
we somehow managed to come up with a
robust ubiquitous language none of us
had any prior experience in online
marketing but nevertheless we could hold
a conversation with domain experts we
understood them they understood us and
to our astonishment domain experts turn
out to be really nice people they really
enjoyed and appreciate the fact that we
are willing to learn from them in their
experience and this smooth communication
allowed us to grasp the business domain
very quickly and to implement its
business logic and yeah it was a very
big and scary monolith but for two
developers in the garage it was just
good enough again working software in a
very aggressive time to market this
diagram sums up our understanding of the
management design in this stage
ubiquitous language and an image domain
model in a monolithic bounded context as
time passed leads started flowing in and
suddenly we were in a rush our self
agents wanted a robust CRM system
customer relations management system to
work with the serum had to aggregate all
incoming leads groups them based on
different parameters distribute those
leads across multiple sales desks around
the globe and it also had to integrate
with our clients internal systems both
to complement our leads with additional
information and to notify the clients
about changes in the LEAs life cycles
and of course the serum had to provide
as many optimization opportunities as
possible for example we needed the
ability to make sure that agents are
working on the most
needs to assign leads to agents based on
their past performance and
qualifications and to allow a very
flexible solution for calculating agents
commissions and since all these
requirements didn't quite fit any
existing of the soft products we decided
to roll out our own CRM system our
initial implementation approach was the
good old lady light will call every now
and then Greg eight and shoehorn there
with huge monolith but this time
something felt wrong right from the
start we noticed that all too often we
were adding awkward perfect C's to
aggregates names like CRM lead and
marketing lead marketing campaign and
CRM campaign and interestingly we never
used those prefixes in conversations
with domain experts somehow they always
understood the meaning from the context
and one day it dawned on me there was a
chapter with something about context and
that big scary book so I went back and
this time I read the blue book
cover-to-cover
I learned that bounded context solve
exactly the same issue that we had
experienced they protect consistency of
the ubiquitous language also by the time
one vernon's book came out implementing
the measurement design and from it I
finally understood that aggregates
aren't just data structures but they
play a much more important role by
protecting the consistency of the data
so it took a few steps back and design
decided to redesign our initial CRM
solution to reflect these revelations
first of all we divided our monolith
into two distinct bound contacts
marketing and CRM we didn't go with
micro services here or anything like
that we just did the bare minimum we
need
to protect our it because language
however in this new bonnet context we
were not going to repeat the same
mistakes we did in the marketing context
no more an image domain models here we
would implement a real domain model with
real by the book aggregate in particular
we promise that each transaction will
affect only one instance of an aggregate
instead of an ORM the aggregate itself
will define the transactional scope and
the service layer will go on a very
strict diet and all the business logic
will be moved into the corresponding
aggregates frankly we were so
enthusiastic about doing things the
right way finally but soon enough
it became apparent that modeling proper
domain model is damn hard
relative to marketing context everything
took much more time it was almost
impossible to get a transactional
boundaries right the first time way to
evaluate at least a few models test them
out play with them only to figure out
later that the one that we hadn't
thought about before was the correct one
the price of doing things the right way
was high a lot of time and sooner than
later it became obvious obvious no
chance in hell we are going to meet the
deadlines and then our management
decided to help us they uploaded
implementation of some of the
requirements to the base
yeah store procedures and this one
decision did so much damage now not
because sequel is not the best language
for describing the business logic no the
real issue was a bit more subtle this
situation produced an implicit bounded
context with its boundary dissecting one
of our most complex business entities
the lead
the result was two teams working on the
same business component implementing
closely related features but with
minimal interaction between them and of
course there were there was no
ubiquitous language between those teams
literally each team had its own
vocabulary to describe the business
domain and rules the Conway's law kicked
our asses big time the models were
inconsistent there was no shared
understanding knowledge was duplicated
here and there and rest assured when
this business logic had to change the
implementations went out of the out of
sync just like that a complete nightmare
needless to say the project wasn't
delivered anywhere near on time and was
full of bugs nasty production issues
that had flown under the radar for years
corrupting our most precious asset our
data the only solution for fixing this
mess was to throw away the old
implementation and to rewrite the lead
aggregate from scratch this time in the
proper boundaries which we did a couple
of years later wasn't easy but the mess
was so bad there was no other way around
it
and to sum it up at this stage our
understanding of the main team in design
look like this ubiquitous language
protected by bounded context and instead
of an anemic domain model everywhere a
proper domain model everywhere and of
course a crucial part of the man driven
design is missing here subdomains there
are types and their effects on
implementation strategies
initially we wanted to do the best job
possible but we wasted a lot of time and
effort on building domain models for
supporting subdomains and as Eric Evans
put it not all of a large system will be
well designed and we had to learn it the
hard way
and we wanted to use the core knowledge
in our next project after the CRM was
rolled out we've noticed there was an
implicit domain spread across marketing
and CRM
whenever the process of handling
incoming customer events was modified we
had to introduce changes both in
marketing and CRM and since conceptually
this process didn't belong to any of
them we decided to extract this logic
into its own dedicated bound context we
call that event crunchers and since we
didn't make any money out of the way we
move data around and we couldn't use an
off-the-shelf solution here it looked
pretty much like a vanilla supporting
subdomain
we design it as such nothing offends at
this time just an simple ETL like
transaction scripts and this solution
worked great but for a while as our
business evolved we implemented more and
more features right here behind people
asked us to put some flags a flag to
mark a new contact to mark a new lead to
group them based on specific brands on
other parameters etc etc and eventually
those simple flags have evolved into
real business logic with complex rules
and invariants now guess what happens
when you implement complex business
logic as a transaction script now what
happens this happens
what started out as an ETL script grew
up to be a fully fledged core domain and
since we didn't adapt our implementation
strategy we ended up with a huge ball of
mud each modification to this codebase
became more and more expensive quality
went downhill and at some moment we were
forced to rethink our implementation we
did it about a year later by the time
the business logic grew so complex it
could only be tackled with event
sourcing so we factored this code into
an advanced horse domain model with
other bounded context subscribing to its
events and we had a very similar
experience in another project one day
our sales desks managers had asked us to
automate a simple yet tedious procedure
that until then they had been doing
manually calculating commissions for
sales agents again it started pretty
simple once a month just calculate the
percentage of each agent sales and send
the payments reports to the managers as
before we contemplated whether or not
this was our core business domain and
the answer was no we are not inventing
anything new here they're not making
money out of this process and if there
was an option to buy an existing
implementation we definitely would sorry
we definitely would so not core not
generic but a typical supporting
subdomain therefore again we didn't go
crazy over his design just some active
record objects orchestrated by a big
service layer once this process became
automated boy did everyone become
creative about it our analysts wanted to
optimize the out of it they wanted
to try out different percentages and
they wanted to make them functions of
sales prices they wanted to unlock some
additional commissions based on
business goals etc etc guess when this
implementation has broke down and indeed
it did break down again the codebase
became an unmanageable ball of mud any
new features turned out to be very
expensive
bugs started to appear and when you're
dealing directly with money even this
tiniest bug can have some serious
outcomes since I'm being recorded you
can ask me during the break why am I
telling this as with crunchers at some
point we couldn't bear it anymore we had
to completely throw away the old code
and rewrite it from ground up this time
is an event sourced to main model but
let's see what happen here just as in
the case of event crunchers the business
logic was the business domain sorry was
initially categorized as a supporting
one but as the system evolved it
gradually mutated into a core business
domain we found ways of making money out
of this process however there's a
striking difference between these two
bounded context for the bonuses we had a
ubiquitous language and even though the
initial implementation was based on
active records we could still have
ubiquitous language you know crud is not
is not a bad word if your domain experts
are speaking about creating reading
updating and deleting but as the
complexity grew the language got more
and more complicated as well at some
point it could no longer be modeled as
active record objects and this allowed
us to notice the need for a change in
the implementation strategy much earlier
than the case of crunchers so we saved a
lot of time here by not trying to fit a
square peg in a round hole thanks today
because language
and that's what our vision of the deal
looked like at this point pretty much
classic one he because language bond
context different types of business
domains and implementation which depends
on the type of the business domain and
the fifth bounded context that I wanted
to talk about is called market and hub
our management was looking for
profitable near-vertical they pondered
why couldn't we use our ability to
generate massive amounts of leads and
sell them to smaller clients once we
didn't work with before so they decided
to give this idea try and as I said this
project was called marketing hub and
since this domain was defined as a new
profit opportunity by the business by
the management it was clearly a core
business domain therefore design wise
here we pulled out the heavy artillery
adventures domain model secured s and
back then one buzzword started gaining
lots and lots of traction microservices
so we decided to give it a try as well
that's what's our solution look like
small services each had its own database
both synchronous and asynchronous
communication between them on paper it
looked like a work of art in practice
you are laughing for a reason
not so fast we naively approached micro
services thinking that the smaller the
service the better so withdrew service
boundaries around the aggregate in the
DD lingo each aggregate became a bounded
context on its own and again initially
it looked great it allow us to implement
each service according to his specific
needs only one would be using event
sourcing and the rest will be state
based aggregate and all of them could be
maintained and evolved independently
heaven however as the system grew the
services became more and more cherry
almost each of them needed data from all
other services to complete some of it
some of its operation the result what
was intended to be a decouple system
ended up being a distributed monolith an
absolute nightmare to maintain there was
another issue we had with this
architecture we had used the most
complex patterns for modeling the
business logic event sourcing and domain
model we carefully crafted all those
services and interactions between them
but it all was in vain behind this
complex architecture stood a very simple
business logic so simple it could have
been implemented using active records
turned out that despite the fact that
was considered a core domain by the
business it had no technical complexity
in it the business people were were
looking to make money not by clever
algorithms but by leveraging our
existing relationships with other
companies the result technical
complexity was much higher than business
complexity and when these two differ
greatly we usually call it accidental
complexity and this architecture ended
up being exactly that accidental
complexity it was clearly over
engineered so though those are the five
bonded contacts that I want to tell you
about marketing CRM crunchers bonuses
and marketing help as I said in the
beginning we have more systems that's
not all because based on this five it
may sound like we're a bunch of losers
who can do anything right
but I wanted to show you the bounded
context that we learned from so now
let's see what we've learned from this
experience first and foremost the
ambiguous language for me
ubiquitous language is the most
important part of the main driven design
this is the core domain of ddd the
ability to speak the same language with
domain experts proved to be in the spec
indispensable for us it turned out to be
a much more effective way to share
knowledge than documents tests and even
JIRA and more than that the ability to
hold the conversation with domain
experts for us was a major predictor of
project success like like in our
marketing context when we just started
our implementation was far from perfect
but the robust TB CODIS language
compensated for their architectural
shortcomings and we were able to deliver
the project's goals in the CRM context
we screwed it up unintentionally we had
two languages described in the same
business domain this led to lots of
problems and even though we've strived
to have a proper design because of the
communication issues we ended up with a
huge mess in the event crunchers this
project started as a simple supporting
subdomain so we didn't invest in the
business language but when the
complexity started growing we regretted
this decision big time even though we
had to redesign the project it would
have taken us much less time had we
initially started with a business
language like we did in the bonuses
project here the business logic became
orders of magnitude more complex but the
biggest language allowed us to notice
the need for change in the
implementation strategy much much
earlier and speaking of supporting
subdomains
it doesn't really matter what kind of
business domain you are working on core
supporting or even generic our take on
it right now is that having ubiquitous
language is not optional for any of them
and we've also learned to invest in the
ambiguous language from early on it is
practically impossible to fix a language
if it has been spoken for a while in a
company like in the case of our CRM
system we were able to fix the
implementation here wasn't easy but
eventually we did it but that's not the
case for the language to this very day
some people are still using the
conflicting terms that were defined in
the original implementation also if you
take care of the ubiquitous language
early enough it's very cheap many have
the impression that it will be expensive
to allocate domain experts time for
interaction with IT people not true this
at our case our domain experts were from
their past experience were sick and
tired of software engineers trying to
act as if they know better how to solve
problems in business domains they have
no clue in and that's why they were so
cooperative in willing to help next
let's talk about the main types we all
know that according to domain driven
design there are three types of business
domains core domains the stuff that the
company is doing differently from its
competitors to gain competitive
advantage for example in our case it's
the different way we are managing our
campaigns the different ways we are
optimizing them the different ways we
mark most promising leads the algorithm
that matches leads to agents to to
maximize the chances of conversion all
the stuff that we had to implement
itself because no one else is doing it
in the same way supporting domains is
all the stuff you do that you do
differently from others but
it doesn't provide any competitive edge
for example in our case in marketing we
had a creative catalog so there was no
existing solution for creative catalog
so we had to implement our own but
nothing special complex about it
graphic designers who just upload new
files edit them delete them boring
business domain and finally generic
domains generic domains are the stuff
that everyone is doing in the same way
those are the solved solutions those are
the well known algorithms that everyone
is using for example encryption
algorithm or medication algorithms all
the stuff that will be much more
expensive and risky to invent yourself
than to just use an existing solution
now it's a common practice to use this
categorization to drive design decisions
for domains use the heavy artillery
build a domain model with DES ladies
technical patterns or event sourcing
supporting domains can be implemented
with some rapid application development
framework because frankly their most of
them are very simple there is no complex
business logic in them and generic
domains the solved problems in many
cases are cheaper and safer to buy or
adopt then to implement yourself however
this model didn't work well for us
the thing is companies and especially
startups like ours tend to change and to
reinvent themselves over time businesses
evolve new profit sources are evaluated
others neglected and sometimes
unexpected opportunities are discovered
as a result business domains types
change accordingly speaking of our
company I think I have experienced
almost all the possible combinations of
such changes for example adventures and
bonuses both started as
pouring domains but once we discovered
ways of making money out of these
processes they became our core business
domains in the marketing context we
implemented our own creative catalog
nothing very special or complex about it
however few years later an open-source
project came out and it offered the same
functionality and even more features
than we originally had so we threw out
our implementation and replaced it with
this product supporting domain became a
generic one in the CRM context we had
this algorithm that evaluated and
identified the most promising leads we
will find it over time tried various
implementation to get Hackett but
eventually we replaced it with a fully
managed machine learning model running
on AWS technically wise a core domain
became a generic domain we've also seen
our marketing hub context what started
as a core domain ended up being a
supporting domain since the competitive
edge he resided in a completely
different dimension and of course we
have quite a few examples in our
industry of companies that turned
generic domains into their core business
for example Amazon and their AWS cloud
now once this kind of change happens
your design should evolve accordingly
failing to do so in time will lead to
lots of accidental complexities and pain
architectural pain therefore instead of
making design decisions based on domain
types we prefer to reverse this
relationship for each domain we design
its implementation strategy first no
gold plating here the simplest design
that will do the job and from this
design we did use the domains type the
first benefit of this approach is less
waste your implementation is driven by
the requirements
and it's not going to be over engineered
as it happened for us in the marketing
hub context and it's not going to be
under engineered has that happened for
us in the bonuses context second
reversing this relationship creates a
dialogue between you and the business
and some sometimes businesspeople need
us as much as we need them because if
they think that something is a core
business but you can hack it in a day
and probably some questions should be
raised about the viability of that
business on the other hand whatever
domain is considered as a supporting one
by the business but it can only be
implemented with a domain model or event
sourcing and that's where things start
to get interesting there are two options
first maybe the business people got a
bit over creative with requirements and
ended up with accidental business
complexity it happens in such case the
requirements can it probably should be
simplified second it might be that the
business can employ this domain to gain
an additional competitive edge but they
didn't realize it yet has that happened
with our bonus module in such a case you
are helping your business to identify
new profit sources and opportunities
much faster now how do you choose this
implementation strategy at Interlagos we
identify a couple of pretty simple
heuristics that allow us to streamline
this decision-making process the most
important decision you have to make here
is how are we going to model the
business logic in code and here we have
four options for patterns first
transaction script simple
straightforward procedural script
absolutely nothing fancy just make sure
that each operation is transactional
either it succeeds or fails
second active record same procedural
cold-ass transaction script but instead
of accessing the database directly it
operates on active record objects that
abstract the persistence mechanism in
the dealing of this pattern is also
known as in anemic domain model both
those patterns were defined in martin
fowler's book patterns of enterprise
application architecture and another
pattern from this book is domain model
and I will use it I will use it as an
overarching term for domain driven
design technical partners such as
aggregates learning object repositories
etc and finally we have event source
domain model it is based on the same
principles as domain model only but
using event sourcing only events are
used for representing changes in the
aggregates life cycles now you can
decide which of these patterns you
should use by answering the few
questions about your business domain
first does domain in question deal with
money directly require deep analytics or
require an audit log by law if the
answer is yes you need event sourced
domain model second how complex is the
business logic is it more complex than
some input validations does it have
complicated business rules and variants
if it does use the domain model third if
on the other hand the business logic is
simple
then how come how complex are the data
structures if you've got some
complicated object trees with
relationships between them go with the
active record and lastly if the answers
to all those questions were negative use
a simple transaction script now once
you've decided which of these patterns
to use it becomes a trivial job to map a
suitable architectural pattern
in most cases adventures in requires
secures the main model requires
hexagonal architecture use layered
architecture for active records and for
transaction script in many cases you can
even do away without layers but there is
one exception here and that's secure
secure s can be very useful not only for
event sourcing but for any of these
patterns but I will get back to it in a
minute now let's say you've chosen an
implementation strategy but over time it
started breaking under its own weight
for example you've been using active
records but maintaining and modifying
the business logic started to become
painful this pain is a very important
signal use it it means that the domain
has evolved and it very well might be
that it's time to rethink its type and
its implementation strategy if the type
has changed talk with the domain experts
to understand the business context if
you need to redesign the implementation
to meet the new business realities don't
be afraid of such a change once this
decision of how to model the business
logic is made consciously and you're
aware of all the possible options it
becomes much much easier to react to
such a change and to refactor to the
more elaborate pattern now let's talk a
bit more in depth about Secours
historically secure s is closely related
to event sourcing if you're doing event
sourcing in almost all the cases you
need secure s but it's crucial to
understand that event sourcing and
secure s are not the same instead there
are two conceptually different patterns
event sourcing is a way of modeling a
business domain CQRS on the other hand
is an architectural pattern it allows
you to represent this
same data in different persistent models
for example for event source and you
have the event store for writing data
and projections for reading same data
but persisted in different models we
found that secure s can be very
beneficial for all kinds of business
domains even for those implemented a
simple transaction scripts or active
records in such cases you can do
projections out of the persistent state
we call them state-based projections and
by using sakura-san this way we've taken
lots of complexities for example in the
marketing context despite the fact that
the vast majority of the business
domains in this bounded context where
were implemented as active records we
used the relational model for reading
and we projected a model for searching
data in elastic search and then we use
some smart caching mechanism to project
flat files that can be read straight
from s3 service again same data but
persisted in different models also
Sakura stands for command and query
segregation responsibility segregation
don't be too dramatic about this
definition there is no point in having
your commands void the system which
executes the command it should know the
result whether the command succeeded
already has failed if it has failed why
it failed
what were their messages even a Dacian
fails what exactly fail how to notify
the clients therefore as Jimmy burger
suggested yesterday at his talk
we also returned data when executing
commands as long as this data comes from
the database which is used for writing
data as long but let's strongly
consistent
so our commands can return data but our
queries cannot modify that that's how we
define securest for us and finally let's
talk about bonnet context and internals
we've tried quite a few strategies for
decomposing a system into bounded
context first we tried linguistic
boundaries we split our initial monolith
into marketing and CRM context to
protect our ridiculous language next
we've tried domain by domain based
boundaries and most of our business
domains were implemented in their own
bonnet context for example crunches and
bonuses we also tried dedicating a
bounded context for a single aggregate
this approach had very limited success
in the marketing hub project but later
on we have extracted
a lot of business entities out of the
marketing monolith into dedicated
bounded context and in this project this
approach worked much much better and
finally I also shown you how we
dissected an aggregate into two
different ball of context this strategy
can be called suicidal boundaries don't
ever ever try this at home okay if you
take one thing out of this presentation
don't do it that's it but seriously as
this paper says correct boundaries are
important for peaceful coexistence of
systems and teams in our case so after
trying out many ways of doing it I'm
going to show you the strategy for
setting the boundaries that we are using
right now first of all we have to
understand that despite the fact that
they have been used interchangeably
later lately bonded contexts are not
microservices each micro-service is a
bounded context but not each bounded
context is a microservice the goal of
Bonnell context is to protect you
because language by making sure that
each term of
language has exactly one meaning to make
sure there are no conflicting models in
the same bounded context in the same
system for example as I said previously
in our original design of the CRM system
we had terms with multiple meanings lead
in campaign according to the major
redesigns principles we split this model
such that each term had only one meaning
in each bounded context microservices on
the other hand are more of a technical
notion the goal of the micro-services
based architecture is to decompose a
system into a set of decoupled yet
coherent components and the thing is
there are different ways to decompose a
bounded context into micro-services but
not all of them are equally good some
are more susceptible to changes across
the boundaries of the services for
example as a result of refraction or
changes in the requirements and when you
have to change your boundaries usually
it's very very painful
therefore to minimize those painful
changes we have to be very careful when
choosing service boundaries if only it
was that easy
as who did the hand said finding
boundaries is really hard there is no
flow chart for that and this statement
has profound implications since there is
no flow chart the only way to find the
right boundaries is by making some trial
and error work yourself which means by
definition there will be mistakes there
is no way around it so let's acknowledge
this and only make mistakes that are
easy to fix and try to avoid doing the
fatal ones in my experience it is much
cheaper safer and easier to extract the
service out of a bigger one then to
start with services that are too small
and merge them later
why because usually
those changes are hard and teams keep
delaying those changes and as time
passes by they mutate into those balls
of mud therefore currently we prefer to
start with bigger boundaries and
decompose them later as more knowledge
is acquired about the business now how
big should the initial boundaries be the
less you know about the business domains
the wider the initial boundaries are so
for more complex domains start with
bigger boundaries but for simpler ones
like supporting domains or generic
domains we start decomposing a bit
earlier when we try to decompose to
fine-grained services early on as in the
case of marketing hub we ended up with
the distributed monolith on the contrary
the marketing context started up as a
month but it was decomposed later on we
extracted campaigns publishers vans
creative catalog and again it's evident
even here the simpler the domain is the
more narrow are its boundaries hence our
rule of thumb base start with bigger
boundaries and decompose if needed of
course is again more to my knowledge so
those are the five practical advices I
wanted to share you because language is
not optional the main types change
embrace these changes use them to make
your design more resilient learn the ins
and outs of the four patterns of
modeling business logic use CQRS to
represent the same data in multiple
models but don't be too dogmatic about
the segregation and bounded contacts are
not micro-services always decomposed
bounded context but divine divide them
further to more fine grade services
micro services as
gained domain knowledge and the summit
sum it all up I want to quickly
reiterate our current approach to
implementing the management design we
all will always start with building a
ubiquitous language with our domain
experts in order to learn as much as
possible about the business domain to
protect the language our initial
decomposition strategy follows the
linguistic boundaries of the ambiguous
language in other words making sure that
each term bears only one meaning in its
bounded context and there are no
conflicting models inside it by
analyzing the use cases we identifying
the business domains in each bounded
context and and this design the
implementation of each domain by
following the heuristic that I've shown
you earlier
from this design we did use the types of
business domains at play and verify them
with the business sometimes these
dialogues this dialogue leads to changes
in the business requirements because we
were able to provide a new perspective
to the product owners and finally as
more domain knowledge is acquired we
decompose the bonnet context further
into more fine-grained microservices but
of course only there is a good reason
for decomposing them and if we compare
our vision of domain driven design now
to the one we started with
I would say that the main difference is
that we went from aggregates everywhere
to ubiquitous language everywhere and
since I've told you how the story of
internal was started a few words on how
the story ended about a year ago we were
quiet about we were required by our
biggest client one of the leading
trading companies in Israel of course I
cannot say that our company succeeded
only because of domains
design but I can say that we were able
to survive despite the fact that we were
in what we call in Israel started mode
what's called startup mode in Israel in
the rest of the world is called chaos
constantly changing business
requirements priorities aggressive
timeframes and a very small R&D team
almost through all history of our
companies we had four developers
including the team Miller so the main
German design allowed us to tackle the
complexities and to keep delivering the
work in software that's about it
thank you we have eight minutes for
questions if you have any the once we
become aware of those possibilities the
refraction became much easier because
the differences between those approaches
are much more gradual from transaction
script to active record you just
abstract those data model data
structures and keep the business project
that manipulates them the same from
active record to domain model you move
the business logic to those aggregates
and play with their boundaries and for
event sourcing it's basically the same
aggregates but you model the changes as
a sequence of events but the boundaries
which the important thing about
aggregates they stay the same
any more questions
we decided to keep all the changes we
thought about having snapshots but
honestly the lifecycle of lead is not
that big and we stored our events in
dynamo DB table it was cheaper to keep
them there yeah you understand yeah so
does it say the same logic applies here
as well the lifecycle of lead is let's
say the biggest aggregate we had had
about 500 events and to rehydrate from
the events took no time so why bother
yeah yes yeah so yes if the question was
did we succeed to achieve a proper
domain model yeah a side-effect free
domain models yeah so for example in the
CRM when we did the refactoring we
wanted to distill this core domain as
much as possible because CRM had a lot
of entities in it and we wanted to
distill only the important parts and the
important important part was the lead
aggregate itself that's it all the rest
different organizations groups desks etc
not interesting so yeah so fully to
achieve this side-effect free domain
model for leads for example in the
marketing domain we did it later for
campaigns campaigns as well yeah so the
question was how did our store with
micro services end up we fell in love
eventually it took some some time to
work on our relationship it wasn't easy
but eventually it worked and yeah yeah
yeah yeah I would say it's mixed but the
breaking point for us honestly I wasn't
sold on this name micro services because
it's Micro Micro and I couldn't
understand what should be MicroBot its
lines of code and then someone said
about pizzas used to feed the teams and
we can feed our whole company mr. Peters
so I work in the same monolith no the
realization that finally down on me that
service is something that the system
does the outracing interface the work it
provides for the other components so
for me currently micro service micro
services are above the minimizing this
external facing interface so naively you
can say that okay so you have a micro
service with only one operation so it's
like the ultimate micro service but it
doesn't work that way because it has to
integrate with other micro services and
then you have to expose additional
endpoints it's like what rent a shop
calls the public door of the service and
those integration points are like a huge
back door so it's not really a micro
service and it takes some time to find
the balance how to divide the system
such that all the services in it could
be called micro services but once we got
to this definition things got much much
more easier
yeah so the question is Eric Evans said
that the bond of contact should have
strong boundaries to protect it from the
rest of the system what I said that
knows not each bonded context is a micro
service it is definitely a service but
it doesn't necessarily answer my
definition of a micro service
so definitely service it definitely has
a strong boundary
yeah so first of all it's a great book
when we have when we have juniors
joining our team that's the book they
have to read first of all and but
regarding this point the question was to
model the Nicktoons domain-driven design
book suggests dividing system into
bounded context following the business
requirements and use cases in our case
we try to do it but those the
assumptions we made for example at the
first version we had almost always had
to change them for the second version
because four core domains the business
people they have no clue what they want
no they they have a clue what they want
they want money they don't know how to
achieve it so they're changing their
opinions and they're inventing new
features and they do affect those
boundaries so that's why we decided to
keep the boundaries wide let them
stabilize on their ideas come up with
the best solution after a few iterations
and only the entity composed the system
yeah yeah exactly so yeah so the comment
was that the business rules that were
not supposed to change actually change
any more questions one two three sold no
more questions and a shameless plug
[Applause]